Britain
was taking a beating from the German ships
and submarines and were looking for something
to build a ship out of that couldn’t be
destroyed by torpedoes, or at least could
take a major pounding without incurring a
fatal amount of damage.
With steel and aluminum in short supply, Allied
scientists and engineers were encouraged to
come up with alternative materials and weapons.
A scientist named Geoffrey Pyke was the king
of alternative ideas (as you’ll see in the
Bonus Facts below).
One of his ideas was to build a 2,000 foot
long, 300 foot wide and two million ton carrier.
Pyke named his project Habbakuk, a biblical
reference that seemed to mirror the project’s
goal: “…be utterly amazed, for I am going
to do something in your days that you would
not believe, even if you were told.”
(Habakkuk 1:5, NIV) Unlike in the Bible though,
the ship’s name was spelled with two b’s
and one k, which is thought to be simply a
spelling error that was repeated so many times
that it became official.
Besides the ship’s size, what was so different
about Pyke’s vessel was that it would be
built of ice.
There is no real limit on the availability
of ice; it’s easy to make, fairly durable
(except in warm temperatures), buoyant, and
very easy to repair when damaged.
Further, repairs can be made extremely quickly
with the right equipment, even during a battle.
The ship was also to include 40 dual-barreled
gun turrets, as well as other anti-aircraft
guns, and an airstrip that could accommodate
up to 150 fighter planes or twin-engined bombers.
Pyke was able to sell Winston Churchill on
his plan in 1942, including Churchill stating
it should be given the highest priority.
In testing, though, it was discovered that
ice might not be as strong as the ice-bergs
that Pyke modeled his idea on.
It turned out that ice frozen into blocks
for the hull could be broken very easily with
something as small as a hammer.
The project was temporarily abandoned as a
result.
However, later that year, a New York polytechnic
firm added cellulose- sawdust, wood chips
and paper shreds- to water and froze it for
a much more promising base structure for such
a ship.
Not only was it stronger than straight frozen
water- with as little as 4% of wood pulp added
it made it as strong as concrete, pound for
pound- it was also much slower to melt and
more buoyant.
Pykrete, named after Geoffrey Pyke, could
also be cut like wood and easily milled into
shapes like metal.
There was one problem though- melting and
refreezing would cause warping in the structure.
Tests showed that a pykrete ship would eventually
sag unless consistently cooled to around 3°
Fahrenheit.
To maintain this, the ship’s surface would
have to be covered in insulation and it would
need a refrigeration plant and duct system.
To test the feasibility of getting around
this problem, a small scale version of the
Habakkuk was constructed in Alberta, Canada’s
Lake Patricia to experiment with insulation
and refrigeration possibilities and to see
how it would stand up to artillery shelling.
The test ship was 30 feet wide by 60 feet
long, weighed 1,000 tons and was kept refrigerated
with a one-horsepower engine, which was sufficient
to keep it from melting even through the hot
summer months.
In ballistic testing, it was determined that
a direct torpedo hit would only cause about
a 10 foot crater in the hull, which was insignificant
given the size of the proposed ship.
Thus, it would be nearly impervious to torpedo
attacks for all practical purposes, as it
would take a huge number of torpedoes and
other bombs to sink the ship.
So even if the ship was broken up, the Axis
powers would have had to invest a massive
amount of their resources in a given area
to do it (particularly considering the arsenal
of aircraft the ship carried), which would
have weakened them significantly on other
fronts during the attack.
If they were unsuccessful, the ship could
be easily and quickly repaired right on the
spot.
So overall, the test ship made the full size
version seem like it might actually work out.
At this point, it was estimated that construction
on the real Habakkuk would cost $2.5 million
(about $32 million today), which is a bargain
for a ship like this.
There were still some hurdles to overcome,
though.
The rudder on such a ship would have to be
massive.
How to effectively mount this in the structure
in a way that would be resistant to attack
was a problem, as was controlling such a rudder.
Also, the amount of wood pulp needed would
have impacted paper production; while this
ship used significantly less steel than most,
the steel tubing it did need for reinforcing
the structure would have depleted reserves
for conventional, proven warships; a huge
amount of cork would also be required to insulate
the ship; and, finally, the ship’s top speed
of just six to seven knots (6.9 to 8.1 mph)
was deemed too slow, even with it being fairly
torpedo-proof in terms of the main structure
itself.
In the end, these problems, combined with
the fact that during the planning phase the
range of aircraft had increased significantly
to the point where the need for a floating
island became less necessary, ultimately sunk
the plan.
While the plan to build Habakkuk was short-lived,
its prototype was surprisingly resilient.
It took three hot summers to completely melt
the smaller version
of
the boat.